[Applause]
[Music] The
beloved who raised the head of the entire nation, and
we say to you a thousand thousand congratulations from here from the
Gaza Strip. All love and respect for you, and we ask God that the
cup be your ally, God Almighty willing.
[Applause]
Today is a match, God willing, it will be decided. The Moroccans are very
happy people.
[Music]
[Applause] The
Moroccan national team is an Arab national team, which means it qualified and reached
these roles for the first time in its life. It is really
there for him. I hope he takes the World Cup,
even if, for example, he is with Argentina and I am
Argentine, so he supports Argentina
[Music]
[Applause]